bonsoir bienvenue de 7,8 société tous
les quinze jours sur téléphiles soixante
dix huit pour parler des sujets qui font
l'actualité
et pour cette nouvelle émission nous
nous intéressons au harcèlement à
l'école c'est un sujet encore un peu
tabou nous on en parle de plus en plus
le 26 novembre dernier le ministre de
l'éducation vincent peillon a présenté
des mesures et puis dans les yvelines
comme dans les autres départements il
existe depuis un an des référents
harcèlement un chiffre toutefois
éloquent pour parler de ce sujet un
élève sur dix seraient concernées alors
nous allons essayer d'en savoir un petit
peu plus sur comment détecter les signes
du harcèlement évoqué les nouvelles
formes peuvent être par exemple cyber
harcèlement et puis évidemment lé
conseil à donner aux parents et aux
enfants pour déculpabiliser et peut être
délivré de la parole le retour de -3
référente chantal de pulsions roussillon
bonsoir vous êtes assistante sociale
conseillère technique référente
harcèlement dans le département vous
vous êtes plutôt en contact avec les
parents des victimes de harcèlement à
votre côté votre binôme 1 on peut dire
ça comme ça la quête valfré dini vous
êtes proviseur vie scolaire et vous
êtes-vous en lien avec les chefs
d'établissements et puis avant d'exercer
cette mission sera aussi intéressant
vous avez été notamment proviseur
adjoint dans des établissements
notamment à guyancourt en face de vous
karim hajji bonsoir vous êtes
conseillère oc 2 à 2 qui dépend de
l'académie ou fait partie d'une équipe
de 9 personnes et vous intervenez à
chaque fois qu'il ya un problème dans
les établissements scolaires et puis la
parole des parents qui se rapportait ce
soir non sans par pierre pro doc selon
la fcpe des lives in alors je les dis un
enfant sur dix seraient concernés par le
harcèlement j'ai envie de tout d'abord
reposé cette première question autour de
la table qu'est ce que le harcèlement
qu'est ce qui différencie le harcèlement
par exemple d'un conflit dit classique
que dans une cour d'école
deux gamins qui se bouscule
ça peut définir le harcèlement par
rapport par rapport à un titillement par
rapport à une bagarre c'est que quand
des enfants se bagarre il ya un sujet il
ya un objet autour de la bagarre est
l'objet du harcèlement n'est pas un
objet justement ça peut être une qualité
physique ça peut être une différence une
stigmatisation sur une différence et il
n'y a pas un objet
comme appliquer ma gomme
mais le harcèlement c'est plus sur la
personne sait plus sur la personne en
elle-même et c'est de façon continue et
répété dans le temps il ya une notion
temporelle qui est très importante dans
les questions de harcèlement donc c'est
une fois un gain un enfant une cour
d'école
le petit is un petit peu sûr parce qu'il
ya un peu un plus gros peut-être un
petit ou un peu trop grand ça c'est pas
très grave mais quand ça ça bien
régulièrement ça peut devenir du
harcèlement c'est ça est-ce que c'est
facile à déceler le marseillais
jean paul
n'était pas facile à déceler c'est pour
ça que c'est
on en fait une pause nationale je dirais
parce que justement dans le processus de
l'art seulement le harceler très vite se
renferme et les signes qu'il lance
ce s'activent dirait doucement et
sûrement et avant qu'ils puissent ray
être repérés comme justement provenant
de harcèlement il peut se passer
énormément de temps des semaines des
mois des années donc c'est compliqué
puisque effectivement dans les signes
qui sont lancés par les enfants
rien ne permet de penser que ça peut
être du harcèlement et donc l'essentiel
pour tous les adultes ce soient des
professionnels ou les parents c'est que
on
rentre dans les hypothèses si je puis
dire
qui peuvent être posées dès lors qu'un
enfant ne va pas bien
le harcèlement fasse partie des
hypothèses la pause et voilà est-ce
qu'il a perdu un parent précemment
est-ce qu'il est maltraité est ce que il
a une difficulté scolaire majeur ou est
ce que il est harcelé par exemple on va
parler un les signes qui doivent alerter
mais je voudrais aussi peut-être au
bouquin vous pourriez me répondre le
harcèlement alors on a l'impression que
c'est au collège on a l'impression que
plus tôt au collège plus tôt à l'école
qu'à un moment il peut intervenir à
partir de quel âge on peut voir des
harceleurs est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
des erreurs tout tout petit tout petit
oui ça paraît incroyable enfin bien
pédopsychiatre jan chan pris avec lequel
on travaille souvent on nous disait qu'à
partir de 6 ans on peut parler de
harcèlement dans la mesure où c'est
l'âge de raison donc l'enfant incapable
de distinguer le bien et le mal donc il
a conscience qu'il s'acharne en tout cas
qu'il fait mal as tu nous fais rien l
enfant de l'âge de 6 ans peut harceler
un camarade oui
ça paraît un peu monstrueux comme ça
fait peur alors après le harcèlement
prend des formes différentes selon les
âges c'est à dire que voilà quand on est
aux primaires l'élémentaire on va
surtout se taper dessus se donner des
coups de pied là qu'on va vers les plus
grands on va davantage abouti
renseignement qui serait plutôt d'ordre
moral psychologique d'accord 400 alors
justement les signes qui doivent
inquiéter à l'armée
enfin vous êtes assistante sociale un
repli sur soi un isolement un manque
d'appétit
un décrochage scolaire à un moment donné
de l'agressivité aussi parce que le
harceler peut essayer de se défendre
voilà toutes sortes de signes qui
peuvent justement révélé autre chose que
du harcèlement mais le harcèlement
peut occasionner ce type 2
de difficultés chez l'enfant qui
qui très vite et c'est très fort dans
les témoignages un des adultes très vite
s'enferme parce que très honteux de la
difficulté là qu'ils rencontrent dans sa
relation aux autres et du fait qu' il a
été ciblé pour
par d'autres qui vont être violents avec
lui parce que qu'on ne parle cyniquement
martyrs aux pieds sur toi sur soi
décrochage de scolaires etc vous allez
très sûr de vous savez ce sont toujours
les mêmes signes qui reviennent c'est
vraiment ce sont des signes qu'on
retrouve chez les enfants d'hier ne vaut
pas bien les enfants qui souffrent pour
une raison pour une autre et un enfant
en souffrance va exprimer donc c'est
chaque enfant mais effectivement exprimé
quelque chose
pour dire qu'il ne va pas bien là toute
la difficulté c'est dans le quotidien
des parents à qui l'on dit souvent en
activité enfin pour la grande majorité
d'entre eux une activité professionnelle
y compris pour les pour les mères de
famille ces voix-là repéré l'enfant qui
justement
parce qu'il est très en te va essayer de
masquer d'abord sa souffrance et ça peut
être ça peut durer très longtemps
jusqu'à un moment où il ne pourra plus
de masques et de cacher et ça va
s'exprimer ça peut s'exprimer d'une
façon très violente et nous avons des
enfants qui disent un jour soit par
écrit soit un copain j'ai envie de me
suicider et personne n'avait repéré
auparavant donc j'ai des plus jeunes l'a
récemment devant des situations
d'enfants de 6e les enfants de 10 11 ans
qui ont exprimé à ce
ce besoin je dirais de mourir et les
parents ne se sont rendus compte de rien
parce que l'enfant arrive si un masque
et
jusque là ses souffrances ses salles en
a honte ils osent pas déranger ses
parents et
pas facile de libérer une parole
d'enfant refaire une première pause dans
cette émission alors justement les
signes qui doivent inquiéter c'est la
question nous sommes allés poser dans
les rues de 50 ans voire six si les
parents les habitants ont conscience
justement de ces signes
agirait qui rentrent de l'école triste
est que le soir il est pas bien la
maison
il pleure il renfermé sur lui même
et après s'il reçoit des coups forcément
il ya des marques physiques un
changement d'attitude notamment au
niveau des sommeils haut niveau sa façon
de s'alimenter et puis ça peut être
aussi un changement comportement ben
vis-à-vis des autres à mon avis faut
dialoguer en parler parler tout
simplement parce que moi le premier j'ai
été victime aussi un petit peu de
harcèlement j'ai pris des claques des
coups de pied et aussi s'en suit
les pas d'autres solutions pour détecter
ça il faut que les parents questionnent
ils surveillent les enfants les
accompagnent il n'y a pas 36 solutions
et puis les profs aussi des enseignants
il faut faire attention à ça parce qu'on
voit bien un enfant qui est malheureux
dans une cour comme il se comporte comme
un petit chien qui est dans un square
battus à cette forme ce que dit ce
monsieur on n'est pas tout tous jeunes
devraient trouver un emploi il n'y a pas
tout jeune on se sent quand même que
c'est resté en lui profondément c'est à
dire que quand on est victime
d'harcèlement étant jeune ça reste même
en tant qu'adulte on sent que les mots
qu'ils emploient sont quand même des
montfort un chien battu on sent que
c'est il parle un peu de lui quand même
on est marqué à vie on est marqué ça
n'empêche pas de de pouvoir aller
beaucoup mieux équipés en commentaire
il reste des traces justement quel est
le travail que vous faites quand vous
êtes confrontés à des enfants qui ont pu
libérer leur parole on comprend bien que
c'est pas facile qui viennent qui
viennent toquer à votre votre porte un
numéro de téléphone qui vont s'afficher
au cours de l'émission c'est quoi les
premiers mots
c'est que je te crois déjà rouge ouais
je crois que c'est important de dire
l'enfant qu'on croise qui nous ce qu'il
dit ne pas se cacher derrière l'idée de
la crise d'adolescence où l'idée que
l'enfant affabule ou
ne pas lui dire si du petit harcèlement
que ça va passer non je crois qu'il faut
prendre en compte sa parole c'est
important parce que lui il a vraiment
perdu un peu confiance dans l'adulte
aussi un camp et dans le vert en
combinant la diable en lui bien sûr il
ya évidemment ça fait partie du travail
de reconstruction c'est de redonner
confiance dans le monde des adultes
alors ça dépend aussi du temps qu'il
aura subi du harcèlement mais
effectivement la prise en compte de sa
parole est fondamentale et ensuite en
faire quelque chose évidemment de cette
parole et et rencontrer le plus vite
possible ses parents
essentiel que les parents soient
associés le plus vite possible si
l'enfant s'est exprimé à l'école ci
s'est exprimé à la maison c'est
essentiel que les parents se rapproche
de l'école pour qu'ensuite il ya un
travail d'équipé autour
de la situation des quêtes vous c'est
votre aussi votre travail de croix de
rencontrer justement ces enseignants et
chefs d'établissement alors il leur dit
quoi parce que c'est pas facile de
régler ce type de problème
alors en général nous avons évalué un
petit peu la situation en amont avec
avec chantal pitt y ont donc on a un
petit peu une idée sur le contexte sur
la situation et du cou
moi je ma partie c'est de prendre la
tâche des chefs d'établissement et
d'essayer d'évaluer avec eux la
situation de l'enfant dans
l'établissement de l'élève et ensuite en
fait à la lumière de ce qui le chef
d'établissement me raconte on trouve
j'essaye de trouver ensemble des
solutions pour que le chef
d'établissement puisse prendre de
manière globale prendre en compte de
manière globale la situation de l'enfant
dans son établissement peut y avoir des
sanctions envers ce type e dame un peu
sinon je préfère qu'on peut il doit
c'est peu c'est que je sais que c'est
que les harceleurs doivent absolument
être sanctionné doivent être sanctionnés
population de somsois éducative il faut
que la victime puisse être reconnu en
tant que victime donc c'est très très
important mais le harceleur seule ne
suffit pas il faut aussi que l'ensemble
des témoins puissent il faut aussi avoir
une action sur l'ensemble des témoins en
fait les situations de harcèlement c'est
toujours une situation à 3 il ya
toujours une victime un auteur et des
témoins et sans cette relation à trois
et à le harcèlement ne peut pas exister
donc les témoins font que la situation
de harcèlement existe et vous occuper
aussi des témoins vous appelez des
témoins vers ceux qui ont assisté aux
scènes dollar faible alors en fait nous
les préconisations que l'on fait auprès
des équipes dans les établissements
scolaires c'est bien entendu de prendre
en compte les témoins et de d'essayer de
trouver des actions pour travailler et
d'agir aussi auprès des témoins je
voudrais une autre question alors parce
qu'on a beaucoup parlé d harceler mais
qui sont ses harceleurs est ce que il ya
des milieux sociaux qui sont touchés ce
que c'est des profils qu'on peut repérer
sur peut-être des enfants issus du
milieu violent en tout cas où un peu
violent c'est un peu ou alors vous allez
me répondre non en fait on les trouve
partout on les trouve partout font
partie mon dieu en fait ce sont des
enfants qui ont également une mauvaise
estime de même comme leur seul et mais
ils vont là ils vont essayer de la
réparer autrement et donc en prenant le
pouvoir l'année suivante dominée
quelqu'un d'autre pour essayer justement
de se reconstruire bon c'est pas là la
bonne solution mais en tout cas ce sont
des enfants parfois coin un modèle aussi
ou et tous à la compétition et pousse à
être meilleur que les autres au
contraire qu'ils sont abîmés dans leur
estime d'eux mêmes qui sont dévalorisées
à l'école ou dévaloriser chez eux et qui
à un moment vont chercher à
être un meneur être un leader être
meilleur que les autres et à s'imposer
par la force par la vantardise ou
entendu
comment vous réagissez à tous alors je
conçois que des siècles en
tant que spécialiste de harcèlement mais
ce que ce que ce que j'entends bien
évidemment c'est le rôle de l'adulte et
on s'aperçoit que ce que nous on appelle
la casse de l'éducation nationale donc
tous tous les tous les enseignants qui
sont partis font cas de moins en moins
d'adultes devant les devants les élèves
que ce soit dans les collèges dans les
lycées ou même de dans les écoles et
pour pour soigner le harcèlement il faut
repérer les harceleurs on l'était moins
et ça les adultes quand les adultes sont
pas là il se passe rien à voir donc bien
évidemment les lutteurs référent oui
mais ils sont pas très nombreux
finalement vous avez dit que des
collèges et des lycées où il n'y a pas
grand monde il ya plus d'assistantes
sociales et ya plus de ya plus
d'infirmières à qui on parle finalement
et puis il ya aussi un autre phénomène à
moi donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on parle
aussi sceller les enfants qui sont
harcelés par les enseignants ou les
enseignants harcelés par les enfants ça
c'est une choré monte et ça ça existe
des professeurs qui harcèlent les élèves
on a des exemples nous
à traiter nous depuis que nous sommes
référés n'a pas d'ailleurs de situation
la sorte non parce qu'en fait nous le
cadre dans lequel on intervient d'un
cadre très précis en fait c'est des
familles qui interpelle qui interpelle
l'institution scolaire pour pour les
accompagner à résoudre une question et
non notre notre champ d'action c'est
vraiment le harcèlement entre élèves
d'accord on va confier cette émission a
parlé d'une nouvelle forme de
harcèlement qui est le cyber harcèlement
un kiwi je vous vois effectivement c'est
visible en une forme harcèlement qui est
de plus en plus préoccupante on va
d'abord regarder un extrait d'un spot du
ministère de l'éducation
c'est bon c'est pas méchant c'était
juste pour rigoler un enfant sur dix est
victime de harcèlement à l'école ces
actes peuvent avoir de sérieuses
conséquences perte de confiance trouble
psychologique dépression et même
conduites suicidaires avant qu'il n'en
garde des traces à vie agissons
et on a bon dos du site internet donc
pas hésité parce que si tata avait
particulièrement bien fait il ya plein
de fiches alors le cyber harcèlement
c'est effectivement quelque chose
d'important c'est à dire le fait par
exemple cet enfant qui a un qui est donc
un peu gros et qui prend en photo et les
photos sont envoyés aux camarades et ça
c'est voilà le réseau c'est une vraie
toile donc sa part très vite si la
complexité du sib et racimo
effectivement c'est qu'on va y avoir une
multiplication du coût des témoins et
puis une information qui va très très
vite et dans la photo que les
commentaires aussi qu'on entend
évidemment extrêmement baissant pour
celui qui est visé alors que faire
bah déjà apprendre aux jeunes à utiliser
correctement internet c'est un outil
fabuleux les réseaux sociaux il n'y a
pas de raison de les diaboliser à
condition qu'il soit bien utilisé et
respecter aussi à prendre du coup à nos
jeunes qu'il ya des règles à respecter
qu'on n'utilise pas l'image de n'importe
qui enfin l'image d'une personne
n'importe comment que il ya des
atteintes à la vie privée qui sont
inacceptables et que à la liberté
d'expression correspond aussi des droits
et des devoirs et qu' ils doivent les
respecter en publiant et en envoyant à 6
les images des uns les autres des
commentaires ou diffuser des ragots si
quelqu'un fait effectivement on peut
donner aux parents
qui voient leurs enfants pas bien qui va
les parents apprennent que leur enfin
ultime de harcèlement à la fois du
cyberharcèlement nos coûts de
harcèlement et les premiers conseils que
je crois que le premier conseil que je
donnerais sais c'est que les parents
s'autorise à se rapprocher de
l'établissement scolaire parce que si la
cyber harcèlement ces 24 heures sur 24
c'est à la maison c'est dehors et c'est
dans les cages beaucoup plus juste un
instant parce que c'est vrai qu'on voit
le numéro de téléphone qui s'affiche le
deuxième numéro le 0 800 200 milles
c'est un numéro très important vous me
l'avez dit en préparant cette émission
parce que ces deux numéros pour tout ce
qui est vraiment à très honnête internet
et aux cyber harcèlement c'est vraiment
d une équipe spécialisée sur cette
problème est là c'est dire comment mes
recettes importantes des conseils de
technique et des conseils aussi quant au
droit des
mineurs et des familles à par rapport à
tout ce qui se passe justement sur dans
le cadre du cyber harcèlement donc
appeler ces numéros se rapprocher de
l'établissement scolaire et dans l'idée
qu'effectivement on est bien sûr le
travail des équipes sur celle affaire de
tous ce ne doit pas être là faire que de
spécialistes
on est vraiment sur la notion de travail
des clips et à réfléchir justement dans
l'établissement scolaire avec les
parents sur ce qui se passe comment ça
se passe et qu'est ce qu'on peut mettre
en place pour protéger l'enfant
s'occuper du harceleur s'occuper
justement des témoins mettre en place
aussi des actions de prévention qui se
développe énormément dans des
établissements scolaires est encore à
faire mais il ya énormément de travail
actuellement
en termes de prévention et que les
adultes aussi se fasse confiance dès
lors qu'est la confiance entre les
parents et les équipes des
établissements tout est possible il faut
que l'enfant sent qu autour de lui les
adultes doit être en confiance entre eux
et encore je fais aussi un peu ton de
dire aux parents qu'il faut
déculpabiliser
parce qu'un parent qui se rend pas
compte que son enfant était harcelé que
ça dure depuis des mois c'est pas facile
à détecter entre annonces ebay d'avoir
énormément quand vous avez les parents
au téléphone tu penses que la
culpabilisation doit être juste énorme
alors non seulement téléphone mais
effectivement quand nous les recevons la
direction académique pour toutes les
situations pour lesquelles nous sommes
saisis il ya un niveau de culpabilité
terrible et on ressent et chez l'enfant
et chez tes parents une souffrance
effectivement regard de ce qui a été
vécu et le parent qui se dit mais qu'il
me dise et comment j'ai pu en tant que
parent comment j'ai pu ne pas
reconnaître j'ai mon enfant cette
souffrance parce qu'au moment où
effectivement l'enfant s'exprime à ce
moment là le niveau de souffrance a
paraît il et il peut être extrêmement
important et sont des entretiens de ce
point de vue là qu'elles sont un peu
difficiles et les parents aussi
effectivement donc donc voilà deux fêtes
ce qui est important c'est de leur dire
que c'est un phénomène qu'on prend en
compte depuis peu de temps je dirais en
france que tout le monde découvre et qu'
il n'avait pas peut-être justement les
bons outils les il ne savait pas que ça
pouvait faire partie de la vie de leurs
enfants donc c'est difficile les parents
on ne peut pas tout savoir et
l'important c'est que maintenant qu'on
sait mieux on sait plus c'est qu'ils
soient vigilants fardeau c'est pas
facile d'être parents non c'est pas
facile et pas si c'est un métier qui
s'apprend bien sûr mais je crois que il
faut il faut ajouter que l'on est tous
potentiellement parents de d'enfants
marceline aussi d'enfants harceleur donc
il faut aussi se prémunir contre ça et
je crois que ce qui fait beaucoup de mal
cesser ses émissions de télévision qui
sont
kiki qui fonctionne uniquement sur
l'élimination finalement et les enfants
reproduisent finalement harceler
quelqu'un s'est essayée l'éliminer d'une
façon ou d'une autre et donc faire
comprendre aux enfants que ça reste des
jeux et que dans la réalité la réalité
n'est pas celle là et que le risque est
pas la gauche sont en compétition et du
coup n'ont pas d'autres moyens que
d'harceler pour éliminer
sa pose de problème des notes ici c'est
autre chose je veux maintenant qu'on
écoute les a alors les à elle est élue
maire du conseil municipal des enfants
de guyancourt elle était venue en
plateau sur le 7 8 pour parler dans tout
autre sujet qui était la journée des
droits de l'enfant et malgré tout elle
nous a aussi parlé du harcèlement on va
écouter ce qu'elle disait sur ce sujet
soit toujours facile d'être un enfant
non
c'est pas facile c'est puis c'est à cet
âge là c'est un peu un motif plus fort
aussi
oui enfin ça m'est arrivé de vivre ça
c'est arrivé à des personnes que je
connais c'est
c'est malheureusement la vie
et c'est pas facile pour tout le monde
s'en sortir et
souvent les personnes
les victimes peuvent devenir par la
suite les celles qui font subir le
harcèlement à d'autres personnes il faut
en parler il faut réagir parce que
parfois on s'en bat tout à fait compte
de la gravité de la situation et ça peut
très vite dégénérer ça peut très vite
dégénérer ça on l'a bien compris quand
elle dit les a finalement les harceler
peuvent devenir des harceleurs sait des
choses que vous voyez ça veut dire qu'il
faut vraiment s'occuper
de façon importante du problème c'est
pour ça que ces deux c'est très très
complexe et c'est aussi pour ça que
c'est compliqué à détecter dans les
établissements scolaires parce qu'on
arrive parfois c'est difficile de
détricoter le harceleur du harceler
parce que bien souvent le harceleur
était harcelé le harceler des harceleurs
et du coup le le travail à faire c'est
aussi de un petit peu de remettre chacun
à sa bonne place et que chaque enfant
puisse s'exprimer et puis s'est exprimé
aussi son mal-être ce qu'elle disait
c'est important de parler alors juste
une dernière chose sur le fait que
l'enfant donc on a bien compris c'est
difficile pour lui de parler la peur de
déranger ses parents qui travaillent qui
sont aussi en situation de divorce alors
encore plus l'enfant est replié sur
lui-même et veut surtout pas embêtés
sepang qui se disputent il a parfois
honte de la situation alors qu'il doit
pas en avoir mais la honte comment
comment on fait pour pour libérer une
parole d'enfant et quels sont les
premiers mots sur un parent par exemple
quels conseils on peut donner un parent
qui sent que son enfant est un peu en
perdition il ya quelque chose qui va pas
les premiers mois
alors moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas
forcément de premiers mots à utiliser
mais d'être attentif et de toujours
préserver une bonne qualité de relation
avec son enfant même si c'est un
adolescent qui est un petit peu refusant
mais de toujours montrer des signes à
son enfant qu'on s'intéresse à lui et je
pense que c'est vraiment très très
important et c'est important quand on
est parent c'est important aussi quand
on travaille dans un établissement
scolaire on n'a pas forcément toujours
en tant que parent les bons mots les
mots justes est ce qu'on a dit ce qu'il
fallait on ne sait pas par contre ce qui
est important c'est vraiment que l'on
sente que ses parents s'intéressent et
petit à petit la parole peut se libérer
mais si y'a pas ce sentiment
lanvollon de telle façon n'aura pas
configurer ses proches de son enfant et
s'intéresser à ce qui nous est ici
si effectivement
les parents se rend compte que l'enfant
a l'air d'aller très bien et que
l'enfant ne parle pas peut-être autorisé
là aussi aller vers l'école vers
l'établissement scolaire pour savoir si
dans au sein de l'institution scolaire
l'enfant qui m'ont traité signe là aussi
dont souffre notre inquiétude ne pas
rester isolé dans une situation comme ça
pensez qu'il ya des gens autour de vous
autour d'établissements scolaires c'est
pas avoir peur de l'école comprend les
pâquis a beaucoup d'avoir peur de
l'école qui ont peur d'entrer dans
l'école al en utilisent les outils là
qui sont des numéros à la santé se sont
inclinés pendant toute la durée de
l'émission merci merci en tout cas vous
82 venir sur le plateau et dont les
numéros se sont affichés n'hésitez pas à
les consulter n'hésitez pas à aller sur
le site agir contre le harcèlement à
l'école point où le point fr il est
particulièrement bien fait merci de
votre attention bonne soirée
où